reproduction is the largest phase of any
project because all you're trying to do
is get everything into one place in one
time once it's all there are you
shooting it's over in an instant before
that we were planning for months and
months and months we were working on
this for almost half a year we started
writing in May of 2015 we shot November
2015 riding riding riding riding riding
and then August hits were more or less
finishing the script and there's the
whole okay we should you know yes maybe
yes you're about two feet should be
heading out any day now guys there was a
cool Friday Rosalie I'll see you later
Gary hugs you know what bring it in guys
I'm not gonna see anyone until next year
two and a half months you guys work real
hard man put their heads down close the
door Monday morning rolls around we open
the door Friday rolls around I'm like yo
we're definitely going this time Jake
mix Monday rolls around boom back in
town repeated this process a couple
times we go to Michigan it we actually
start real pre-production however it
taken so long to get everything rolling
that by the time we landed in Michigan
we had a week in five days before
shooting started and we're up against a
heart out like we're our last station
with September 18th the weekend at
Christmas yeah we can have to do
location scouts choreograph the fight
scenes to make any script adjustments to
do a table read to get a costume set to
get the costumes fit to do action
rehearsals to get everybody tactically
trained to the producers credit we send
over an Oregon leading this project we
have three main action scenes so you
need a nice set with each action see we
need a day of rehearsal for each action
scene and you got it you've got that for
each action sand and really really
helped video boards plan it out what
took the actors ran through it even
though we didn't have everything
finalized at every single location the
main thing is it's really important to
just to get people on to these locations
you can just start thinking about what
its gonna look like where you are in
your sense of space there was about four
or five location scouts every single day
where we just go to so many places right
and plan things out see what's working
what's not before we know it our week
and a half was up we'd spent it all
going through the guns
year and vehicles locations so here we
are the first location scout of movie
this is the mansion the movie opens here
and closes here I only do it to plan out
scenes inside the mansion and scenes
outside the mansion non action scenes we
also have to plan out where it takes
going to go where a helicopters gonna go
where a TDS are gonna go where a
gunfights gonna happen this whole bunch
of stuff to figure out locations change
when you get there some things get
better some things get worse today
mostly everything got better there's so
many more rooms and parts of this
building that we just haven't even seen
in the photos yet really great to be
able to actually get here a great
location on to the next one
locations got in the hospital right now
it's super creepy but it's kind of cool
we are at our potential vault one
location it's looking really cool right
now but I see one prom already a lot of
cars are right here at that we're gonna
drive a tank into the sea figure that
out after pulling all these things
together we were left with our first day
of production and that day was intense
for us because that was the first day we
had ever worked with a crew of this size
in our entire lives also just our first
day working with that crew general day 1
of 49